c'est youtube heures a résolu une
affaire non élucidée depuis vingt ans la
disparition des rings pasteur et jérémy
spectacle le 3 avril 2000 ces
adolescents américains de 18 et 17 ans
originaire du tennessee se rendaient à
une fête dans une zone rurale depuis ils
n'ont plus jamais donné signe de vie
dans leur petite ville de sparta des
rumeurs circulent meurtres sordides
trafics de drogue les familles des
disparus espérait quant à elle une fugue
le youtuber exploring would not a
finalement résolu le mystère dans une
vidéo publiée le 4 décembre ce vidéaste
spécialisée dans la recherche de
personnes et d'objets disparu s'est
servi d'un sonar avancées auxquelles les
autorités locales n'avaient pas accès
pour aller fouiller des pendaisons
[Musique]
il a fini par retrouver la voiture des
adolescents les premières expertises
indique que le conducteur aurait
simplement perdu le contrôle de son
véhicule qui aurait fini donc